Oh Joe makes his comeback Kamala Harris
gets whittled down to sizing Barack
Obama has a rotten evening I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show oh
[Music]
man what a debate last night the spills
the thrills the chills the radicalism I
know it was actually incredibly boring
but when you break it all down it's not
quite as boring as it seems and the good
news for you is that if you missed the
entire debate you saved yourself three
hours and now you're gonna get
everything you need to know in the next
45 minutes or so it's just gonna be
great you're gonna love it
okay so let's just jump right in the big
themes of the night right off the top
Barack Obama was a loser is not
according to Republicans this is
according to Democrats Barack Obama must
have been sitting home going what me why
me what what he is the most popular
Democrat in America he has been for
welcome for a decade and the Democrats
on stage except for Joe Biden because
they were attacking Joe Biden decided it
was necessary to take Barack Obama and
then drive over him with a bus and then
put the bus in Reverse and then drive
over him universe it was really amazing
so the Democrats because they have to
differentiate themselves from the past
and they have to look forward to the
future they've decided that Barack Obama
has to be left behind that was theme of
the night number one theme of the night
number two all Joe Biden has to do is
survive now that is a difficult task for
him he was stumbling a little bit last
night he looked more energetic he looked
better than he had in the past but he he
didn't look as energetic as he did even
5 or 10 years ago obviously he looks old
up there that's gonna be a problem
against Donald Trump but all he had to
do was not make a big boo-boo and acquit
himself fairly decently he did that last
night so that means that Biden looks a
lot more durable today than he did
yesterday because he is the most
electable Democrat out there everybody
knows this it is true from the national
polling it is true from the state
polling Joe Biden's positions are closer
to the mainstream than any of the other
Democrats on that stage and also it
turns out that his old boss Barack Obama
still kind of a popular dude so Joe
Biden all he had to do was survive he
did and then the third theme of the
night was that Kamala Harris had a giant
fail now Kamala Harris was always a bit
of a paper tiger meaning she is good on
the attack but she has no defense she as
a boxer she lets her hands down way too
much and and because she does not
actually have any core
principles in which she believes that
means that she makes herself vulnerable
to anybody who does have core principles
she moves around a lot
innate silver the pollster over at 5:38
he has suggested in the past that Kamala
Harris looks a lot like Mitt Romney did
for the Republicans or she seems
shifting on her positions on paper she
looks pretty good but in reality not
nearly as good as a candidate Kamala
Harris was exposed last night she was
exposed in a very bad way and this means
that this race looks like more and more
it's gonna boil down to a two-person
race between Joe Biden and Elizabeth
Warren if it boils down to Joe Biden
versus Elizabeth Warren Biden is the
nominee and we got a trump Biden race
because that dynamic looks a lot like
Hillary versus Bernie circa 2016 why
well when you look at Hillary versus
Bernie what really differentiated the
two was their voting base Hillary's
voting base was a lot more minority than
Bernie Sanders's was this is also true
of Joe Biden and if it comes down to a
Biden versus Warren race there's a
significant likelihood that at some
point in their Barack Obama does weigh
in on the side of Joe Biden particularly
if it becomes clear that Joe Biden is
gonna sweep all the southern states and
Elizabeth Warren is gonna do nothing in
those states but Kamala Harris has
collapsed last night was actually the
big story of the night that Joe Biden
survives Camilla Harris basically gets
ko'd but not by Joe Biden now all of
that is just sort of the introduction to
what was a fascinating debate in many
ways again it was Democrats running
directly to the left right off the cliff
except for Joe Biden who is standing
there going guys what are you doing why
but virtually every other Democrat on
the stage may be Senator Michael Bennet
who nobody's ever heard of all the other
Democrats were racing to the left racing
to the left and again this means that
Barack Obama by contrast looks like a
Republican if you were just listening to
that debate and you had no idea which
party Barack Obama belong to you would
assume that Barack Obama was the
preceeding Republican president that's
what you would assume it was incredible
and what made him more incredible is
that this whole thing led off with Tom
Perez who was sort of the rah-rah guy
both nights he gets up there beforehand
he warms up the crowd like a bad comic
straightens his tie and goes out there
like Rodney Dangerfield and he says he
starts off by saying who else mrs. Obama
who else mrs. Obama big cheer and then
when the debate starts like nobody mrs.
Obama man we hate that guy here is Tom
Perez leading it off am I the only one
well when you contrast him with Trump
yes when you contrast him with the other
Democrats it turns out a lot of
Democrats in the primary base not in
love with Barack Obama now after the
debate you could see that the Democratic
commentators couldn't believe it they
couldn't believe it they were saying why
are these Democrats attacking Barack
Obama joy reid and joe scarborough on
MSNBC they're beside themselves what are
the democrats doing they're
disassociating themselves from the most
popular politician of the last 35 years
what what in the world
here is MSNBC I couldn't believe what
Democrats have just done it was weird
for me to watch about 40 almost 40
minutes of primarily attacks on the
Obama administration's policies it was
odd it took I mean
de Blasio made a full-on attack of
Obamacare essentially said we have no
working health care system in America
but hello we have Obamacare yeah it's
almost as if the debate forgot who's
president because the attacks on Donald
Trump I don't I don't remember his name
being mentioned that much and so it was
odd for me for these candidates to
debate changes in health care and their
different policies on immigration as if
Trump doesn't exist and all of this of
course is being driven by the fact that
Joe Biden is in fact the front-runner so
if you want to go after Biden you have
to go after Obama there's just no way to
do it otherwise cuz you can't separate
off Biden from Obama Biden's entire
record is wrapped up with a bow with
Obama ISM so very very fascinating kind
of stuff okay so the debate leads off
right before the debate everybody is
focusing in on it's gonna be Biden vs.
Harris and those are gonna be the fights
that really matter as it turns out those
were not the fights that really mattered
all that much Biden acquitted himself
well against Harris's we'll see but the
person who actually took out Camille
Harris was not Joe Biden it was Tulsi
Gabbard who came in from the top rope
from left field piledriver
knee to the skull it was brutal we'll
get to that in just once I get started
off by the way before the debate starts
off it starts off with Joe Biden
greeting Harris and on a hot mic saying
take it easy on me kid there's a little
bit of what that sounded like it's clip
[Applause]
and she says oh okay okay well again
everyone was sort of expecting her to go
hard after Biden everyone took their
shot at Biden and they all missed and
they almost okay so we'll get to all
that in just one second first nowadays
there are a lot of different types of
cars on the road there's no way that the
auto parts store located near you can
have all the parts that you need for
your car at the proper price well this
is why the interwebs exists the
Internet's which are great it turns out
Joe Biden doesn't know what an Internet
is but the Internet is fantastic and one
of the things that it provides to you is
the ability to get the kind of car parts
that you actually need rockauto.com does
it all for you it's a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years you go to Rock Auto comm to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they've got
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or daily driver and get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog it's unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
best of all prices at rockauto.com
are always reliably low they are the
same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers well I spend up to
twice as much for the same exact parts
instead head on over to Rock Auto
dot-com go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car
truck and make sure that you write
Shapiro's in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you that helps our show it also helps
them know to continue advertising with
the show go to Rock Auto calm and write
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know we say instant some
money save some money on your car parts
obviously okay so you can see the
democrats begin to run some we're gonna
run through some of their opening
statements they're a bunch of candidates
on the stage so bill de blasio his most
radical candidate on the stage and he
was going to wreck Lee after Joe Biden
and he was going directly after Barack
Obama he was amazing to watch like here
was Bill DeBlasio the most annoying MIT
serial groundhog murderer Bill DeBlasio
giant weirdo huge cut he's basically
like John Kasich if John Kasich were
simultaneously a giant a communist and a
serial groundhog murderer that's that's
Bill DeBlasio in a nutshell so here is
Mayor Bill DeBlasio leading off by
smacking Joe Biden and Kamala Harris in
a bid for attention Joe Biden told
wealthy donors that nothing
fundamentally would change if he were
Calma Harris said she's not trying to
restructure society well I am when I'm
president we will even up the score and
we will tax the hell out of the wealthy
to make this a fairer country and to
make sure it's a country that puts
working people first okay and then
people in the back start chanting at de
Blasio because de Blasio hasn't arrested
a police officer who's involved in the
death of Eric garner so it was a mess I
mean right from the outset it was a mess
and de Blasio kept doubling down on this
yeah in his conclusion in his concluding
statement he comes right back to where
he was saying that he's basically a
socialist and he wants more socialism if
he thinks this is winning campaign not
Barack Obama socialism go for it Mayor
Bill if we're gonna beat Donald Trump
this has to be a party that stands for
something this has to be the party of
labor unions this has to be the party of
universal health care this has to be the
party that's not afraid to say out loud
we're going to tax the hell out of the
wealthy and when we do that Donald Trump
right on cue will call us socialists
well here's what I'll say to him Donald
you're the real socialist the problem is
it's socialism for the rich nobody
understands what the health of this
country we don't have to take the
anymore
we can fight back I love that he says
that he's waiting for the collapse and
nothing happens right he's waiting for
the applause
he's like we'll say Donald you're the
real socialist nobody's like um what now
so socialism bad or is it good confused
to catch up that was Bill de Blasio's
opening pitch then you had the execrable
kirsten gillibrand who's just awful
awful awful awful she leads off trying
to be inspirational by saying something
very very silly my grandmother taught me
that nothing's impossible she spent two
generations organizing women in upstate
New York my mother taught me nothing is
impossible do you want to get something
done just tell me it's impossible um
okay um here is something that's
impossible you ever being president
there it is right there that's the
impossible thing Gillibrand
was was on her high horse the entire
debate yeah I'm gonna talk in a little
bit about Kamala Harris getting
destroyed on the stage
Gillibrand actually really got destroyed
on the stage as well so we may as well
go through kirsten gillibrand because
this is probably the last we're gonna
hear of her she's not gonna make the
final round of debates so we're gonna
bid a fond farewell to Kirsten
Gillibrand you know why Kirsten
Gillibrand is going Miller because she's
the worst let me give you an example so
Kirsten is clipped 35 Kirsten Gillibrand
is talking about race in the United
States and she suggests that she is
going to be fantastic
talking to white people about race
because mommy is gonna lecture all the
white bees about what it means to be
woke I mean this is really her case it's
unbelievable
she's so bad at this so bad I think as a
white woman of privilege who is a u.s.
senator running for president United
States it is also my responsibility to
lift of those voices that aren't being
listened to and I can talk to those
white women in the suburbs that voted
for Trump and explained to them what
white privilege actually is that when
their son is walking down a street with
a bag of M&Ms in his pocket wearing a
hoodie his whiteness is what protects
him from not being shot well I mean also
not getting into a confrontation in
which you're beating a man's head
against the pavement is a great way of
not getting shot as well it turns out
but in any case there was Kirsten
Gillibrand she's going to convince
that's gonna be her pitch to Trump
voters shall win them over by going into
their house and lecturing them on their
white privilege and that their sons
should be shot on behalf of not having
white privilege smart stuff from Kirsten
Gillibrand Joe Biden actually put her
through a wall it was one of the more
delicious moments of the debate this
clip 43 children tried to attack Joe
Biden on women citing an old op-ed and
then Biden responded by finishing her
off in brutal fashion so wonder Vice
President Biden's analysis am i serving
in Congress resulting the deterioration
of the family because I had access to
quality affordable day care I just want
to know what he meant when he said that
I was a long time ago and here's what it
was about it would have given people
making today $100,000 a year tax break
for child care I did not want that I
wanted to child care to go to people
making less than $100,000 and that's
what it was about as a single father who
in fact raised three children for five
years by myself I have some idea what a
cause
my very beginning my deceased wife
worked but we had children my present
wife has worked all the way through
raising our children I was deeply
involved with all these things I came up
with the it's honest proposal to see to
it the women were treated more decently
on college campuses you came to Syracuse
University with me and said it was
wonderful I'm passionate about the
concern making sure women are treated
equally I don't know what's happened
except that you're now running for
president the crowd loses it Kirsten
Gillibrand goodbye see you later
Kirsten children okay so we're getting
rid of some of the less important
candidates and then we'll get to the the
actual red meat of this debate so when
things began to get hot okay when things
began to get hot it was really all about
Biden so everybody decided to level
their guns hit Biden I'm giving you sort
of an intro to the various candidates we
have to introduce the players before we
get to the fisticuffs so Tulsi Gabbard
who ended up being a major player in
this particular debate she led off with
a differentiating factor she has
military experience
now her foreign policy may be garbage
and when I say maybe I mean it really is
she has a very isolationist foreign
policy she ran cover for Bashar Assad in
Syria in the midst of him murdering his
own citizens but Tulsi Gabbard does have
a different pitch if she didn't have
such a crazy foreign policy should be a
major threat to trump she really but she
would be if she weren't a nut on Syria
then Tulsi Gabbard would really be a
dangerous candidate here is Tulsi
Gabbard talking about her military
experience this is her pitch I love our
country it's why I enlisted after 9/11
I've served as a soldier for over 16
years to play twice to the Middle East
and serve in Congress now for almost
seven years I know what patriotism is
and I've known many great Patriots
throughout my life and let me tell you
this Donald Trump is not behaving like a
patriot Gabbard would be a real threat
to Trump as we'll see she's very good at
what she does there's one point here
that the most critical moments of the
debate where she basically ends Kamala
Harris on the stage and then there's
Andrew yang so Andrew yang didn't get
any sort of attention in the last debate
he showed up to this debate and he
actually did get some attention for good
reason now because there's so many
candidates differentiating factors
matter so he didn't wear a tie in the
last debate in or a tie in this debate
and the fact is that because
didn't wear a tie it actually gave him a
very solid pitch hey first of all I like
Andrea I will admit it I know Andrea
personally he came on the Sunday special
we had a really good conversation about
his universal basic income proposal with
which I disagree but I think that he is
a technocrat who wants to improve the
workings of government I think that his
ideas are not ideas that I agree with
but he certainly has a more interesting
take than most of the Democrats on the
stage
this is Yang's clip to what he said at
the end of the debate was really his key
moment I wouldn't be surprised if he
picks up a couple of points here heads
couldn't stop talking about after the
last debate it's not the fact that I'm
somehow number four on the stage in
national polling it was the fact that I
wasn't wearing a tie instead of talking
about automation in our future including
the fact that we automated away four
million manufacturing jobs hundreds of
thousands right here in Michigan were up
here with makeup on our faces and our
rehearsed attack lines playing roles in
this reality TV show it's one reason why
we elected a reality TV star as our
president and he is not wrong about any
of this it's why the yang gang may
actually start to become more of a thing
I said one second we're gonna get to the
the candidates that everyone actually
cared about last night they'd be Cory
Booker Kamala Harris and Joe Biden gets
their intro statements and then we'll
get to the fisticuffs right this is all
the set up for the big round-robin WWE
nitro okay wasn't that exciting but it
did have its moments we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the quality of the sheets upon
which you sleep now I know that you
don't think too much about that sort of
stuff because you just figure I'll go
down to the local Bed Bath & Beyond I'll
pick up some sheets at real retail
prices and it doesn't matter if they're
good or not they have a high thread
count I don't know anything about sheets
here's the fact you need a great set of
sheets how can you make this happen you
need to go to bowl and branch everything
that bull and branch makes from bedding
to blankets is made from pure 100%
organic cotton which means they start
out supersoft they get even softer over
time well then branch sheets are so good
that once I got some I actually threw
away all the other sheets that we had
and bought more bull and branch eats
because they just our quality you can
buy directly from Boleyn branch so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to a
thousand bucks in the store but when
bran sheets are only a couple of hundred
bucks everyone who tries Boleyn brand
sheets loves them shipping is free you
can try them for 30 nights
and if you don't like them you can send
them back that's not gonna happen
they're fantastic there's no risk no
reason not to give them a try to get you
started right now my listeners get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets at
bol and branch com promo code Ben go to
bowl and branch comm today for 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets
that's bol and branch com promo code Ben
bull and branch comm promo code Ben
they're fantastic go give them a try
okay so Cory Booker then introduces
himself and Booker is desperate for
attention he made sure that rosario
Dawson packed him his angry eyes last
night mr. Potato Head he always makes
sure that he brings his angry eyes well
last night he brought his angry eyes and
he talked about how President Trump was
very very bad for insulting Baltimore
dude you ran away from being mayor of
Newark and Newark was no better off than
when you were before you were mayor and
you're gonna talk about the failures in
our inner city like you are part of the
failure in the inner city last week the
President of the United States attacked
an American city calling it a disgusting
rat infested rodent mess Donald Trump
from Charleston to Baltimore to even the
border is using the tired old language
of demagogues of fear mongers of racists
to try to divide our country against
itself we know who Donald Trump is but
in this election the question is who are
we as a people okay Booker has nothing
now it's really funny because the press
afterward was saying what a great job
Booker did I didn't see it I didn't see
it I think the conventional wisdom on
Harris was right I think the
conventional wisdom on Biden was right I
think the conventional wisdom on Booker
is totally wrong but Cruz got nothing
he's going nowhere
he's rehearsed he's annoying forget it
done okay then there was camel hair so
commonly heard this was supposed to be
her second big push right
she had her big push in the first debate
and in that first debate she smacked
Biden around on federal forced busing
even though she actually opposes forced
busing and then she smacked Biden around
on health care and then she doesn't
actually have a health care plan well it
turns out that this was a bad night for
Kamala Harris it didn't start off all
that great she started off by botching
her opening line here she was and I am
prepared to march with you to fight with
you for the
best of who we are and to successfully
prosecute the case of four more years of
Donald Trump and against him
I like that she realizes halfway through
that statement that she's just talked
about why she was gonna argue for four
more years that's in trouble she's a
weird moment she was botching things all
over the place then there was Joe Biden
so Joe Biden is the front-runner the
clear front-runner at this point he's
doubling up everybody else's numbers and
he's doubling up everybody else's
numbers because people have a genuine
level of sort of comfort with Joe Biden
they feel like they know him he's old
Joe old reliable Joe well all he had to
do was survive last night he did it kind
of barely right so he started off strong
by the end of the night he was fading in
terms of energy so we will play you the
beginning of the debate and the end of
the debate and you will see the the
benefit of Joe Biden and the drawback of
Joe Biden so here is the benefit Joe
Biden makes people feel comfortable for
whatever reason mostly because they know
him already here was Joe Biden at the
beginning mr. president let's get
something straight we love it we are not
leaving it we are here to stay and we're
certainly not going to leave it to you
okay so this is Joe Biden looking a
little bit more energetic in the crowd
responds because they think Joe Biden
can beat Donald Trump by the end Joe
Biden is grandpa who doesn't understand
the internet and is still using dial-up
for AOL I mean really this is how Joe
Biden concluded so if the rip on Joe
Biden is that he is too old and too weak
and too feeble to go up against Trump
you can make the case based on some of
his performance last night that's the
case he was stumbling over his words
here was Joe Biden at the very end so
everyone pitches their website at the
end of the debates which is stupid okay
everyone who uses the Internet knows how
to Google somebody's name if you're on a
Google tulsi gabbard you're gonna find
her website you want a Google Joe Biden
you can find his website Joe Biden what
he's trying to do here is say that you
should text his name to a number and
instead he just completely Boches it
because he doesn't know what the
interwebz are this is the United States
of America we've acted together we have
never never never been unable to
overcome whatever the problem was if you
agree with me go to Joe 303 300 feet in
this fight thank you very much
go to Joe 3:3 Oh Joe Joe 303 303 Oh
people immediately went online bought
those websites and start redirecting
them to like mayor Pete so what well
done Joe Biden that that did sort of
underscore the rap on Joe Biden which is
that he's still old and doddering but
again it wasn't a bad night for Joe
Biden overall all he has to do is
survive because this Democratic field is
a very weak field that is just the fact
now maybe it is the case that when you
have big fields like in 2016 with the
Republicans the field looks strong until
it begins to coalesce and they know like
wow
this field isn't nearly as strong as I
thought it was but I think that
inherently this is a very weak field it
really is Kamala Harris doesn't have any
experience and she's bad at her job
Bernie Sanders hasn't accomplished
anything in the since the time of the
dinosaurs when he when he first wrote a
brontosaurus into Congress the the fact
is that this field is so weak that Joe
Biden who has run unsuccessfully for
president three separate times is gonna
jet set into the middle of this field
and he and right now best indicators
will probably pick up the nomination so
it was a good night for Joe Biden was a
bad night for Kamala Harrison now we're
gonna get to the fisticuffs now we get
to the fun part hey here is Joe Biden
Pamela Harris Harris had the bad night
so here was Harris being asked right off
the bat what the hell are you talking
about your health care plan and she's
asked by Jake Tapper why no one
understands your health care plan and
her initial response is so weak and so
poor here's what Tom well Harris has to
say well they're probably confused
because they've not read it but the
reality is that I have been spending
time in this campaign listening to
American families listening to experts
listening to health care be obfuscates
rather than just goes on and she
obfuscated she's got nothing no the
reason no one gets her plan is not
because they haven't read it first of
all no one reads campaign plans on
websites the reason that no one
understands your plan is because you
don't understand your plan you made it
up in the last five minutes five minutes
ago now this is where Joe Biden really
launches into Camilla Harris and the and
the veneer of Kamala Harris begins to
crack by the end of this night Kamala
Harris is lying in shreds on the floor
it is a very very bad night for a camel
heiress so Joe Biden goes after Kamala
Harris on her health care plan it
brutal response is that the Senators had
several plans so far and anytime someone
tells you to get something good in ten
years you should wonder why it takes ten
years if you notice there's no talk
about the fact that the plan in ten
years will cost three trillion dollars
if you will lose your employer based
insurance and in fact you know this is a
single most important issue facing the
public and to be very blunt and to be
very straightforward you can't be
President Trump with double-talk on this
plan I mean little mama you can see she
she she cannot she cannot take the heat
and then Michael Bennett the senator
from Colorado who apparently only on
stage for this moment
he went after Harris as well he says
listen what you're talking about is not
math it doesn't make any sense
Sara Harris is my friend as well but I
have to say if we can't admit if we
can't admit tonight what's in the plan
which is banning employer-based
insurance we're not going to be able to
admit that when Donald Trump is accusing
Democrats of doing that as well we need
to be honest about what's in this plan
it bans employer-based insurance and
taxes the middle class to the tune of
thirty trillion dollars do you know how
much that is that is seventy percent of
what the government will collect in
taxes over the next ten years okay she
and she's got nothing right so what does
Harris come back to after all that after
she gets blasted on her own plan which
is a completely unworkable plan Harris
comes back to the same point that
Democrats tried to make last night which
is that anybody who asks a question of
Democrats is repeating a Republican
talking point this is such a weak line
it's the it's the equivalent of Hillary
Clinton suggesting then when people ask
questions about her husband's morality
it was a vast right-wing conspiracy here
is the fact the criticisms of health
care her plan are coming from other
Democrats on the stage it's coming from
Joe Biden and Michael Bennett because
those other Democrats recognize reality
and Kamala Harris simply does not you'll
see Camilla Harris respond it was a very
bad evening for her get two more of that
in just one second first yeah I'm too
busy to go to the post office that's
especially true these days because last
time I went to the post office
I'm telling you city of Los Angeles
crappy at everything they won't collect
your trash they won't clean up the
homeless problem they won't get the open
needles off the streets but if you park
five inches in a red zone for five
minutes and 21 seconds it will give you
a $100 ticket they're amazing at it so
I'm not going to the post office anymore
even though I kind of like the post
office instead I'm using stamps calm
when you go to stamps.com you get all
the services of the post office without
actually having to go there
stamps calm make sure that whether
you're a small office sending invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
or even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps calm can do all of
those things you simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it once your mail is ready just hand it
to your mail carrier or you drop it in a
mailbox it is indeed that simple with
stamps calm you get five cents off every
first class stamp up to 40% off Priority
Mail not to mention that it is actually
a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters stamps calm
it's a no-brainer it saves you time and
it saves you money it's no wonder that
over 700 thousand small businesses
already use stamps calm right now we
have a special offer for our listeners
it includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long term
commitment just go to scams calm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that is stamps
calm enter Shapiro for that special deal
stamps that comes fantastic I use it
personally we use it a daily wire check
them out stamps calm use that promo code
Shapiro okay so Kamala Harris comes back
and she suggests that any criticism of
her crap plan is a Republican talking
point well the one thing she has right
is that if she were ever to make it to a
general election it certainly would be a
Republican talking point because the
American people hate her plan by polling
data Americans want to keep their
employer-based health insurance most
people are pretty happy with their
health insurance
here's Kamala Harris weekly responding
to Michael Bennett we cannot keep with
the Republican talking points on this
you got to stop the reality is that what
undermine Medicare for all plan yes
employers are not going to be able to
dictate the kind of health care that
their employees get they will be able to
make that decision okay no they won't be
able to make that decision is what
you're saying and then Joe Biden
finishes Harris off on all of this and
harkens back to guys like you're
standing up here ripping on a seminal
piece of legislation that Democrats used
to celebrate as a big effing deal in Joe
Biden's words Obamacare here is Biden
responding to Harrison really clocking
her
Republicans are trying to kill Obamacare
for 30 trillion dollars has to only be
paid and I don't know what math you do
in New York I don't know what math you
do learn California but I tell you
that's a lot of money and there will be
a deductible the deduction will be out
of your paycheck because that's what we
required senator okay and he is of
course exactly right about this bad
moment for Kamala Harris who doesn't
actually have a plan on all this okay
then the debate moves on to immigration
I should note here Cory Booker kept
trying to interject it he's such an
irritating human being Cory Booker
Spartacus mr. Potatohead he kept trying
to interject in here to do this why are
we arguing with each other routine cuz
it's a debate because this is what
you're supposed to do and Cory Booker is
the most vicious person on that stage I
mean truly a vicious politician who goes
after everyone and then in their bait
he's just like Chris Christie chris
Christie did the exact same thing in
2016 you go out there and savage
everyone and then he would get on stage
be like why are we all talking about
each other why can't we talk about
Hillary Cory Booker does that same
obnoxious routine last night here he is
on health care well first of all let me
just say that the person is enjoying
this debate most right now is Donald
Trump as we picked Democrats against
each other while he is working right now
to take away he's again it's a debate
pitting Democrats against you cuz it's a
debate mmm nobody Cory Booker's done
okay he's not a thing stop trying to
make fetch a thing he is not a thing
Cory Booker okay meanwhile the Democrats
move on to immigration once again the
Democrats are very radical except for
Biden so who a and Castro leads this
thing off and again he's gonna this has
become a democratic mean basically
whenever a Democrat says right wing
talking points that is code for a
question I don't have an answer to so he
is a Jake Tapper quotes jeh Johnson the
homeland security secretary under Barack
Obama not a Republican we should note
again the transformation of Barack Obama
into a Republican the Affordable Care
Act is a giveaway in a boom for the
pharmaceutical and insurance companies
and immigration enforcement is really
bad it's always been bad and Jay Johnson
was really bad so who Leon Castro who is
the HUD secretary under Barack Obama he
decides that he's going to go after jeh
Johnson the homeland security secretary
under Barack Obama the part of the same
administration right serving in the same
administration and jeh Johnson has said
if you decriminalize border crossing
you're going to increase the number of
people crossing the border illegally
here's who Leon Castro calling that a
Republican talking point from jeh
Johnson open borders is a right wing
talking point and frankly I'm
disappointed that some folks including
some folks on this stage have taken the
bait the only way that we're gonna
guarantee that we don't have family
separations in this country again is to
repeal section 1325 of the immigration
Nationality Act that is the law that
this president this administration is
using to incarcerate migrant parents and
then physically separate them from their
children okay you know who else did that
was Barack Obama you actually don't need
section 1325 if you want to detain
people and then the Flores settlement
obtains and then you have to separate
parents from the kids that is not you
don't need section 1325 to do that this
is just it's a stupid talking point
people who suggest that repealing 13:25
would in any way end the family
separations if Trump wants family
separations that they will happen if he
wants to detain people that attentions
will happen people who cross the border
even legally applying for asylum are
usually detained for a period of time
because we have to process them and
under the Florida settlement you can't
detain people for longer than twenty
days with their children in custody
that means you have to separate the kids
from the parents the system is backlog
Democrats know this it's a dumb talking
point Joe Biden points out that this is
a dumb talking point and who Ian Castro
goes back at him this was I thought the
only moment that was bad for Joe Biden
but even there wasn't particularly bad
for Joe Biden because the fact is that
Cooley and Castro's a nobody and he was
a member of the same administration it
just doesn't work most Americans run
Biden side of the table this argument I
found that who we are excuse me the
secretary we sat together in many
meetings I never heard him talk about
any of this when he was the secretary in
addition to that we're in a circumstance
where if in fact you say you can just
cross the border what do you say to all
those people around the world who in
fact want the same thing to come to the
United States and make their case and if
they don't that they can't have to wait
in line the fact of the matter is you
should be able to if you cross them
order illegally you should be able to be
sent back it's a crime first of all mr.
vice president it looks like one of us
has learned the lessons of the past and
one of us hasn't
all right guts enough to say his plan
doesn't make sense here's the deal the
fact of the matter is that in fact when
people cross the border illegally it is
illegal to do it unless they're seeking
asylum people should have to get in line
that's the problem all right Joe Biden
sounds a lot more reasonable than hooli
and Castro here so hooli and Kass are
obviously running to the left of the
party on immigration but Biden sounded
written out he's still stumbling he's
still fumbling so all of this is true
about Biden right he is his tumblr he is
a fun blur he is going to stutter he is
going to he's going to get choppy in his
wording but what he is saying sounds so
much more reasonable to the vast bulk of
Americans than anything the other
Democrats are saying that he survives
last night and he does so looking pretty
good now we're gonna get to Bill
DeBlasio who was the weapon of choice
against the Obama administration in this
debate we'll get back to him in just one
second first you know it's very
important that if you're a responsible
person one of the things you have to do
as an adult is put together a trust or a
will now my wife and I have both we have
a trust we have a will it is deeply
important if you got kids even if you
don't have kids you haven't any asset
base at all you need a trust you need a
well but it shouldn't cost you a fortune
you shouldn't have to go to a buy our
lawyer in order to do that instead it is
the perfect time to do it
national make a will month over at Legal
Zoom for more than 18 years Legal Zoom
has developed a straightforward way for
you to protect what you care about the
most your family and then making sure
that your assets go to your family in
case god forbid something happens to you
this starts with a last will or a living
trust estate plan by the way you want to
protect yourself against the estate test
estate tax that Democrats are surely
going to jack up you need a living trust
if this sounds confusing don't worry
LegalZoom can help you out of really
isn't they have a ton of online
resources for you to figure out what's
right for you if that's not enough their
network of Independence attorneys can
provide advice if you need more
direction make things easier for those
you care about the most checkout legal
zooms last will and living trust estate
plans now during national make a will
month at legalzoom.com for special
savings be sure to enter promo code been
in the referral box a check out that's
code Ben for special savings only at
legalzoom.com
where life meets legal go check them out
right now legalzoom.com and make sure to
enter promo code been in the referral
box at checkout
we're gonna get to the rest of the
democratic debate coming up first you
have to go subscribe over at daily
wire.com first of all we do have an
event coming up August 21st in Long
Beach you should go to Daley wire.com
slash backstage and check that out yes
we charge you money The Daily Caller has
reported shockingly that we charge money
for tickets for this thing I know it's a
shock but it's actually a lot of fun
we'll see you there also subscribe
because it helps protect us from the
evils of the left that want a censor all
material they don't like your
subscription helps bring you the content
that you want it makes you part of our
team and we are adding such great stuff
behind the paywall I can't even talk
about it yet my business partner will
get mad but it's gonna be so awesome
there's there's a lot and right now you
already get a lot of awesome stuff
including all three hours of the men
Shapiro show live every day as well as
taped without any sort of commercials
you get the leftist ears Hydra called
tumblr when you get the annual
subscription we are multiplying by leaps
and bounds the sort of material that you
get when you become a subscriber so go
join up right now at daily wire.com we
have the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
okay so bill de blasio again was the
lead attack dog against Biden and Obama
because he's a communist and so de
Blasio really went after Biden on
immigration and he pointed out that
Obama deported a lot of people which of
course is exactly true and it's fun to
watch Democrats realized that Barack
Obama deported many Barack Obama
deported like three million people by
statistics Donald Trump's is deported
like 250,000 people so it's not even
close here is Bill DeBlasio going after
Biden and Obama million people here and
everyone in theory has broken the law
but they're part of our communities now
they're part of our economy they're our
neighbors why are we even discussing on
one level whether it's a civil penalty
or a criminal penalty when it's an
American reality and what we need is
comprehensive immigration reform once
and for all to fix it
second Vice President Biden I didn't
hear your response when the issue came
up of all those deportations you were
vice president itíd States I didn't hear
whether you tried to stop them or not
using your power your influence in the
White House did you think it was a good
idea or do you think it was something
that needed to be stopped okay and Biden
says well I give him advice but I'm not
gonna explain to you what the advice was
because I was VP we're in the White
House at the time we can sir
this was Cory Booker's one effective
moment Booker then ripped into Biden and
said listen you can't associate with
Obama when it's convenient and then
disassociate when it's inconvenient
president you can't have it both ways
you invoke President Obama more than
anybody in this campaign you can't do it
when it's convenient because that point
is fine it's where Booker goes next
that's insane so every Democrat on the
stage would attack Joe Biden and then
they would move on to a point that was
patently crazy so you'd have hooli and
Castro attack Joe Biden on immigration
and then say we should decriminalize and
basically create open borders you would
have people attack Joe Biden on Obama
care and then move on to but we need
Medicare for all so Booker does that
right now he attacks Joe Biden II says
you can't associate with Obama when it's
beneficial and then say you don't like
the deportations
but then Cory Booker goes to merit-based
immigration is inherently bad because
Biden had said we should bring in PhDs
we should bring in people who are
qualified and Booker's like no we should
bring in everybody okay you just blew
all your credibility because you're now
saying something totally crazy
second thing and this really irks me
because I heard the vice president say
that if you got a PhD you can come right
into this country
well that's playing into what the
Republicans want to pit some immigrants
against other immigrants some work from
okay this is crazy okay now now is it
this is the point every time they attack
Biden they then start pushing a further
left agenda that makes Biden look decent
hey this was true on crime as well so
Cory Booker attacked Joe Biden on his
criminal justice record this is an area
where Democrats think they're gonna make
a lot of hate particularly with black
audiences in the United States they've
been saying for years Democrats have
that the criminal justice system is
racially biased and terrible mass
incarceration police officers randomly
arresting black people that's all by
statistics a lie but Democrats have been
pushing it so here's cory booker pushing
that agenda and again it doesn't end all
that great for cory booker but this is
the attack line mr. vice president has
said that since the 1970s every major
crime bill every crime bill major and
minor has had his name on it and so
those are your words not not mine and
this is one of those instances where the
house was set on fire and you claimed
responsibility for those laws and you
can't just now come out with a plan to
put out that fire
we have got to have far more bold action
on criminal justice reform now here's
where Biden stuck between a bit of a
rock and a hard place here is the fact
what Joe Biden should say is in 1994 we
were at the very tail ends of the worst
crime wave in American history from 1960
to 1994 crime skyrocketed in this
country violent crime particularly in
the inner cities targeting black folks
that is simply a data-driven fact and by
1994 everyone right left and center was
in favor of harsher policing and harsher
sentencing 54 out of 56 Democrats in the
United States Senate voted in favor of
the 1994 crime bill everyone voted from
the 94 crime bill Cory Booker would have
voted for the 94 crime bill and it
brought down crime and what Biden should
say is and that created space for us to
now loosen laws right that's where Biden
should go
he has another line of attack he's other
line of attacks is that Cory Booker is a
freaking hypocrite and he drops that one
and Booker has just blown away in 2007
you became mayor you had a police
department that was you went out and you
hired Rudy Giuliani's guy you and
engaged in stop and frisk you had 75% of
those
tops reviewed is illegal you found
yourself in the situation where three
times the money african-american kids
were caught in that chain and caught up
the Justice Department came after you
for saying you were you were engaging in
behavior that was inappropriate and then
in fact nothing happened
the entire time you were mayor okay all
of that is true all of that is true and
Biden stumbles over the attack and this
again underscores the fact that there
are weaknesses to Biden as a candidate
he's not a terrific debater he's not a
great candidate but again Cory Booker
going to let's free all the prisoners is
a bad place to go okay then finally we
get to the moment when Harris gets
destroyed so Harris has sort of been
sitting in the background she starts off
the debate she basically gets clocked on
health care and then things really go
wrong for her so Harris jumps into the
middle of the rational fray and she's
urged to do so by the CNN moderators
they say you know you had this whole
thing last time around about federal
bussing and Kamala Harris jumps in and
she attacks Biden on bussing again and
you're about to see things go so wrong
for Harris
this is like watching a car wreck in
real time and it was pretty delicious
because Kamala Harris deserves every bit
of what she's about to receive from both
Biden and Tulsi Gabbard it's brutal here
is here's Kamla Harris leading it off
remember she started it
she did not when you start a fight you
got to finish the fight she started the
fight she did not finish this fight here
was Harris going after Biden when Vice
President Biden was in the United States
Senate working with segregationist to
have posed busing which was the vehicle
by which we would integrate America's
public schools had I been in the United
States Senate at that time I would have
been completely on the other side of the
aisle and let's be clear about this had
those segregationists their way I would
not be a member of the United States
Senate Cory Booker would not be a member
of the United States Senate and Barack
Obama would not have been in the
position to nominate him to the title he
now hold okay so it is without federal
busing Barack Obama wouldn't have been
president sure sure okay so here and
then Biden comes right back at her and
he points out a lady you support the
exact same bussing policy that I do and
you're a hypocrite senator Harris was
Attorney General for eight years in the
state of California there were two of
the most segregated school districts in
the country
in Los Angeles in in San Francisco and
she did not like I didn't see a single
solitary time she brought a case against
them to distinguish them secondly she
also is in the situation where she had a
police department when she was there
that in fact was abusing people's rights
okay so Biden sounds a little slow on
the attack right so this is a damaging
moment for Harris but then apparently he
deputized his Tulsa gavel it went in the
back room somewhere he swore her in and
suddenly this turned into the the entire
revenge montage from tombstone because
tulsi gabbard
my god tulsi gabbard brings the hammer
about as hard as i have seen someone
bring a hammer in a presidential debate
since chris christie went after marco
rubio this is brutal she takes a
chainsaw to Kamala Harris rhetorically
speaking obviously she just viciously
murders her this is the meme from The
Simpsons stop it stop it he's already
dead I mean that that's what this watch
tulsi gabbard go after Kamala Harris and
Kamala Harris collapse into dust like
the end of the first part of the
Avengers it's unreal I want to bring the
conversation back to the broken criminal
justice system that is
disproportionately negatively impacting
black and brown people all across this
country today now senator Harris says
she's proud of her record as a
prosecutor and that she'll be a
prosecutor president but I'm deeply
concerned about this record there are
too many examples to cite but she put
over 1,500 people in jail for marijuana
violations and then laughed about it
when she was asked if she ever smoked
marijuana she blocked evidence
that would have freed an innocent man
from death row until the courts forced
her to do so
she kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the state of California and she fought
to keep bail system in place that
impacts poor people in the worst kind of
way the bottom line is senator Harris
when you are in a position to make a
difference and an impact in these
people's lives you did not and worse yet
in the case of those who were on death
row innocent people you actually blocked
evidence from being revealed that would
have freed them until you were forced to
do so there is no excuse for that and
the people who suffered under your reign
as prosecutor oh you owe them an apology
Oh No
and Kamla Harris is she starts she has
the same ticket as Hillary Clinton does
which is that when she gets caught out
she starts to laugh and you can see her
starting to laugh right there Reggie it
gets awkward and she starts to smile she
starts to laugh how worried I don't know
have you guys seen that series on Amazon
called Patriot when one of the opening
scenes is one of the characters standing
next to another character on an empty
street and then a truck starts to pass
by and he just puts his hand behind the
other characters back and throws him in
front of the bus
those were right in front of the truck
Tulsi gabbard's who Kamala Harris oh
were brutal and Komal Harris has no
comeback and that was really the story
of this debate right Joe Biden survives
not a lot of damage done him I think he
did some damage to himself in a couple
of different areas for example so I will
say that there was one point where Joe
Biden suggested that he was going to
eliminate coal and fossil fuels and
fracking in the United States which
that's not going to play in Pennsylvania
where this is still major industry both
coal and fracking here was Joe Biden
saying that Thank You mr. president
clarify would there be any place for
fossil fuels including coal and fracking
in a Biden administration no we would we
would work it out we would make sure
it's eliminated and no more subsidies
for either one of those either any
fossil fuel okay so
again that may come back to haunt him
but overall not a horrible night for Joe
Biden horrible night for Kamala Harris
horrible night for Komal Harris and also
a lot of rich veins of attack opened
against Barack Obama and against Joe
Biden by Democrats that would be better
prosecuted frankly by Republicans than
by Democrats so bottom line is by the
end of this debate Kamala Harris is in
serious trouble
Kamala Harris is candidacy I think is
about over I think that moment that she
was having after the first debate is
basically done and we've seen this in
debates before and Carly Fiorina had a
moment in the Republican primaries in
2016 where she said of vaulted to the
top and then she receded back to the
back and you're seeing the same thing
happen with Kamala Harris with vaulted
near the top and then she receded all
the way back down to 10% last night was
a very bad night for her even CNN was
pointing out what a bad night it was for
a common law Harris the CNN panel just
shredded her this is clip 48 talking
about Kamala Harris's performance last
night she I thought when she was
attacked I don't think she performed
well and she was on the defensive quite
a bit tonight and I it didn't help her
did anyone think she did a good job what
do you think about the job she did I
think she spent a lot of her time
attacking Joe Biden tonight and just
being very just mean-spirited almost in
the way she was just constantly going
after him not that I mean so that turns
you off a little bit yes just brutal I
mean this is hidden panel ripping Kamala
Harris apart and you can see common
ladders knew exactly what had happened
after the debate she was asked about
Tulsi Gabbard and she got incredibly
defensive incredibly defensive here is
Kamala Harris getting so defensive that
it is extraordinarily off-putting the
comma ylim moment is over this is now
becoming a Joe Biden versus Elizabeth
Warren race and it's doing so pretty
quickly here was Komal Harris to
Anderson Cooper trying to go after Tulsi
Gabbard and instead punching herself in
the face did you expect that from Tulsi
Gabbard had had you had interaction
about that in the past
and how do you think it went well I mean
listen I this is gonna sound immodest
but I'm obviously a top-tier candidate
and so I did expect that I would be on
the stage and take hits tonight because
there are a lot of people that are
trying to make the stage for the next
debate for a lot of them it's do-or-die
well yeah and especially when people are
at 0 1 percent or whatever she might be
ow
okay so that that is not gonna be good
for Kamala Harris makes me look like a
jerk because frankly she's kind of a
jerk so bad bad night for Kemal Harris
bad night for Barack Obama fairly good
night for Joe Biden who survives and
moves on to our next elimination round
so that that is where we currently stand
in the democratic race again I think
this is now shaping up pretty clearly as
a Joe Biden versus Elizabeth Warren race
as Elizabeth Warren I think continues to
gain momentum the media keep propping
her up they're tired of Bernie Sanders
if the Bernie bros hold on then Biden
runs away with the nomination if the
burning bros hold on and bernie
continues to carry 20% 15 to 20 percent
then Elizabeth Warren can't break free
and even compete with Joe Biden they
split the vote Biden runs up the middle
takes the nomination he's a dangerous
candidate for Trump he's a dangerous
candidate because he is not nearly as
crazy as the other Democrats because the
American people have a generalized
comfort level with old Joe yeah he's not
as energetic as Trump but he's also not
as controversial as Trump I've been
saying for literally since before the
2016 election that if the Democrats had
run Biden he probably would won I think
that Biden remains the most dangerous
candidate for president Trump I think
the Trump administration knows that as
well okay time for a quick thing that I
hate no things I like today well just do
a quick thing that I hate and then we'll
be out of here
okay quick thing that I hate so I
commented on this on the radio show
yesterday but didn't have a chance to on
the podcast so Mario Lopez has now been
cancelled he's been ripped into by the
left why because Mary Lopez he he
engaged in a grave sin
he suggested that three-year-olds can't
choose their own gender oh no okay
my three-year-old cannot choose his food
he cannot choose his underwear he cannot
choose anything you know why cuz he's
three he is three years old and if you
think that three-year-olds are capable
of choosing their gender that they are
capable of deciding whether they are a
male or female and they're a biological
male for example you are out of your
freakin mind and you should not be a
parent it is that simple now maybe that
kid has problems that are going to has
gender dysphoria or gender identity
disorder maybe those are going to
exacerbate as the kid gets older at
three years old the answer is no you're
a parent and your job is to provide a
solid innocent background for a child is
what Mario Lopez says and then he's
ripped and then he's forced to sort of
back off of it if he wants to keep his
job because we live in this idiotic
cancel culture where if you say
something wrong if you make a boo-boo we
throw you in the boo box from hook
we just throw you in there and we toss
scorpions and snakes Mario Lopez said
this you ready for this here is his
deeply offensive comment that had him
trending number one on Twitter quote I'm
trying to understand it myself
please don't lump me into that whole
group I'm kind of blown away to look I'm
never one to tell anyone how to parent
their kid obviously and I think if you
come from a place of love you really
can't go wrong but at the same time my
God if you're three years old and you're
saying you're feeling a certain way or
you think you're a boy or a girl or
whatever the case may be I think it's
dangerous as a parent to make this
determination then well okay you're
gonna be a boy or a girl whatever the
case may be it's sort of alarming and my
gosh I just think about the
repercussions later on when you're a kid
you don't know anything about sexuality
yet you're just a kid now people are
saying well that's conflated look at him
he doesn't understand gender theory he's
conflating sexuality and gender identity
no he is saying that as you get older
one of the major components of your life
is going to be how you treat your
sexuality that has something to do with
your biology and for example your
hormonal development and your genitals
you might want to know something about
that before you make a decision again I
won't let my three-year-old make
decisions because he's smart for a
three-year-old which means he's dumb for
an adult cuz he's three one day he will
be a smart adult not today man he's
gonna try and jump in the pool without
any sort of flotation device I'm not
going
what if I left my son alone for two
hours he would be dead I'm not going to
let him choose his gender Blair white
who is a transgender woman meaning a
biological male who has gender identity
disorder dive talked with Blair we've
had our long conversations on this this
particular issue
Blair white tweeted out that if you have
a three-year-old who you say is is non
gender conforming then that's like
having a cat that is vegan we all know
who's actually making the real decision
there okay it is not the cat and it is
not the three-year-old because
three-year-olds are not capable of
making decisions along these lines or
basically any decisions at all
Mario Lopez forced to apologise of
course because this is the stupid world
in which we live and people lied about
what he said they said that he was
saying you can't support transgender
kids that's not what he said that's not
what he said he said kids at three don't
make decisions duh obviously true and by
the way if you let your kid at three
make those sorts of decisions you're a
bad parent
end of story because kids at three do
not make any you wouldn't let your kids
decide what to eat you wouldn't let your
kids decide whether to go to school you
wouldn't let your kid decide his bedtime
hours is we wouldn't like your kid to
side their own his gender what what
nonsense what absolute sheer garbage and
silliness alrighty we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show well the
second round of the second Democrat
debate is over and our choice is clear
are we going to stick with mean mean mr.
Donald Trump who has restored the
economy kept the peace and restored the
Constitution - or are we going to go
with a nice compassionate good-hearted
Democrat will destroy everything we'll
talk about it on the Andrew Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin